hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of old versus
new
[Applause]
[Music]
has wax on wax off ever really taught
anybody karate
what did for this idiot the Karate Kid
a hokey but still pretty effective
sports film centered around a kid named
Daniel who moved from Jersey to the
valley and keeps getting his ass whooped
by a group of karate experts named Cobra
Kai oh well could you ever do an old
mrs. new with us in the GI Joe movie the
movie loses anyway he comes across a
maintenance man named mr. Miyagi who
teaches him karate and enters him in a
tournament to fight the bullies and
their crazy fucking teacher head-on this
is a karate dojo not admitting class of
course Daniel wins and they live happily
ever after through three more seasons
what a thought they used later a spinoff
would come around that would not only be
intriguing but just as good as the
original I am of course talking about
the Karate Kid cartoon
[Music]
hell yeah Daniel with mr. Miyagi air
traveling but where's it safe but shrine
look at this they got motorcycles
airplanes Amazon God blossom shut up
[Music]
actually the show was stupid but they
came out with an hour movie like
everybody when I saw the trailer for
this film I rolled my eyes
what Will Smith's son is Daniel and
Jackie Chan is mr. Miyagi it sounds more
like a satirical sketch that doesn't
actual movie but to everybody's surprise
it was actually a well put together then
it had hokey moments like the original
but it actually managed to be passionate
dramatic and still stay true to the
original source material while being its
own creation what the hell a lot but we
are not here to glorify movies actually
we sort of are but we're mostly here to
compare which one of these movies got
the job done better
the iconic original or the new
reimagining which one had more drama
more heart and kept the better balance
what's the better movie then everybody
whacks off - it sounded really bad this
is all vs. new karate kids
[Music]
[Applause]
so what better way to start off the
Karate Kid than by looking at the Karate
Kid
this is the best Karate Kid
now both these actors do a good job
representing their characters and their
age range they're both tough but
sensitive to they're not super strong
but they never back down from a fight
and they're both charming and cocky but
also know what the shut up and focus in
the original Daniel played by Rob Maggio
moves from Jersey to the valley and has
a hard time fitting in the truth you
don't want to hear the truth all you
want to hear is how great it is I do and
may be great for you but it's sucks for
me just like a home with Dre played by
Jaden Smith he moves from one side of
the world to the other so I guess you
could argue he has a little bit more to
complain about we've been here less than
a week and I feel like it's a year here
but nevertheless both represent how hard
it is to fit into a new place you can
also make the argument that because
Smith is younger you'd naturally feel
more sorry for him when he gets beat up
little kids get injured isn't a fun
thing to watch I'm les you're Willy
Wonka but then again it's pretty hard to
watch Maggio get his ass kicked - so I
don't know which one actually leaves a
deeper impact well if I had to choose
and of course I do I have to say Maggio
but to be fair I think a lot of that has
to deal with his age
when you're a little kid it's common to
get in fights and if you lose well
you're a kid it sucks but you're still
allowed to look weak at that age and if
anything it's kind of cool that you were
in a fight to begin with no other kids
gonna fuck with you but Maggio was in
high school a point where standing up
for yourself and acting like a man is a
much bigger deal if you fight when
you're a kid it's just sort of okay when
a parent or teacher comes in to fix the
man when you're a teen that shit goes
right out the window
and your pride suddenly costs a lot more
to defend it I think because of that
macho has a lot more to prove and his
struggle is much more painful and
identifiable he was to be left alone but
not at the cost of his dignity and he's
willing to fight to defend who he is
that does this too but like I said it's
a different age if this kid was beating
on me at that age I'd be like dude mom
there's a fucking crazy Asian kid who
looks like a psycho
he knows kung fu and I am scared
shitless do something in high school you
have no choice you gotta fight and thus
Davis seems much stronger and more
determined
I also have to admit it is refreshing to
see a movie character from Jersey who's
not an asshole okay yeah I make fun of
Jersey every once in a while but even I
know that not every person that comes
from there is totally nuts it's nice to
see an actual positive Jersey role model
you know outside of oh god my face shut
your mouth in dirty little hamster okay
Popeye on crack oh that show rapes me I
also get the feeling that macho is sort
of like Bruce Wayne and hear me out of
this it always seems like he's one step
away from being an evil jerk himself he
always walks that fine line like he
could turn to the dark side at any
moment but that just makes us all the
more thankful that he is a good guy
wants to stay a good guy
and is willing to put his balls on the
line to prove it not only does this make
him more interesting but it makes him a
better role model and a better character
Smith you did great but tango sock is
the more engaging hero point goes to the
old oh that's great flex on
[Music]
remember there are no bad students only
bad teachers and what kind of teacher
makes the student paint offense while
learning karate
indeed mr. Miyagi has become an iconic
image of the old wise martial arts
teacher but Jackie Chan really is an old
why is martial arts teacher so again
this is a pretty close call in many ways
Miyagi is much more deceiving because he
looks older is shorter as not as
physically fit Jackie Chan looks like
Jackie Chan
so his challenge is a little greater to
be visually deceiving but they overcome
that very carefully with the attitude
they gave him he's wise yes but he's
also sort of a lost soul I thought you
were just a maintenance man you sing
only wavy ice so you got easy to fool he
was destined for great things but chose
not to follow it because of something
painful that happened in the past
Miyagi is actually content with where he
is and likes where he lives despite the
fact that he has a very sad backstory
too but there is a lot of weight in
having Jackie Chan be in your kung-fu
movie for example when she is character
mr. Han actually talks about kung foo
it's pretty obvious he knows what he's
talking about because Jackie Chan is
playing him you know he's not gonna lie
about that shit that's another thing in
the remake it's code on code off as
opposed to wax on wax off but mr. Han
actually explains why he used this
method to teach him colorful lifting
everything we do is out doing
he lives in how we put on a jacket I
would take off the jacket then lives in
how we treat people
everything it's a coke before mr. Miyagi
on the other hand never explains why he
had Daniel wax his cars and paint his
fence yeah it's teaching him karate but
why the hell didn't he just oh I don't
know
teacher karate what the cops under floor
anything in the house or a floor I mean
think about it if who's Daniel as well
as the audience but he never actually
explains why why did he teach her this
way is that just showing him the moves
do you think Daniel ever came to that
realization hey mr. Miyagi what get me
paint your fence so a teacher yeah
but why don't you just show me the moves
is to having me paint your fence to
teach you karate you just wanted to
fence painted didn't show yes yes I did
and why'd you have me wax the car Oh
two-for-one diem let's look at the bag
stories mr. Miyagi lost his wife and son
while she was giving birth and was
unable to see her because he was in the
army but with mr. Han he lost his wife
and kid because he was driving the car
and got into an accident so that place
is even more guilt on him because he was
actually the cause of their deaths I was
driving up or something I was so angry I
lost control
I cannot remember whether we arguable I
hope it was something important
this explains why he's such a shut-in
and rarely talks to people with mr.
Miyagi they've never seen like a
concrete reason why to have that tragic
history maybe the idea is that Daniel is
the closest thing to a son he ever had
but even then that's a little vague it's
ironic because I should like mr. Miyagi
more because he's much more confident in
wise but honestly mr. Han is the more
interesting character it's one of the
few times I didn't see Jackie Chan at a
performance and I sort of forgot that he
actually can do drama he's done in the
past and can do it quite well if in the
right movie but aside from that mr.
Honda is more complex and has more
weaknesses to overcome they both learn
from each other and make one another
stronger in the original it was very
much teacher taught student but here
they actually teach each other which
feeds into the whole balance subtext
that both films are working with Plus
mr. Han can hold fucking fire in his
hand it's just awesome again both do
wonderfully but mr. Han is the more
juicy performance allowing for a lot
more strength and heart to be shown and
developed point goes to the new I think
you talk too much attitude
and now for my favorite part the
villains do these guys even need an
introduction I mean the Karate Kid
villains they should practically have
their own movie we're gonna look at them
right now alright I've gone on and on
about the crazy karate teacher from the
first movie and what an enjoyable nut he
is you're a pushy little bastard ain't
you I like that
yes yes very clever old man the ball is
in your court now but after the
tournament is over it says I possess the
golden trophy making me next to the
Walgreens drugstore god I need a
girlfriend
he's dude on the other hand the main
bully who picks on Daniel he's just
sorry your run-of-the-mill jerk
the remake on the other hand switches it
around in the new film it's the teacher
that's just sort of the run-of-the-mill
jerk and the student that seems totally
batshit insane
I mean look into his eyes he's fucking
nuts clearly these two should've been
switched around the Asian kid should
have been with the American teacher and
the American student should have been
with the Asian teacher that way these
two could have their very own reality
show mercies apiece
but I digress which of these are
actually the better villains well it all
depends on how you look at it if you're
going for what's memorable the originals
got it down I mean you're never gonna
forget these guys they're so over the
top but if you're going for what's
actually menacing the newer film would
probably come closer now that the other
villains didn't have threatening moments
but they're just so many silly moments
that keep sucking you out of it the
teacher in the remake is a little bit
more interesting because you get the
feeling he has it out more for the
teacher not the student he's always
calling the student of thing he means
very little to it some kids at Kaiser
say double sure you thought on this
y'all lose the dog food outside mmm ah I
think he's more interested in showing
mr. Honda his methods are better and
stronger and that anyone who questions
it is going to get their ass handed to
them in the original I don't know what
this guy's problem is he's just a
fucking asshole who wants to start a
fight because he's a fucking asshole and
it's open season
though to be fair it is a bit more
rewarding to see the bully in the
original hand the trophy over that is in
the remake but again that might be an
age thing in the remake I keep thinking
the kid is gonna steal it for himself
haha mine bitches so to that film's
credit it's pretty fucking awesome when
all the teachers students bow to mr. Han
look at that face that's pure friggin
gold tough call but I am gonna go at the
new ver as much as I love these nuts
even I had to admit they're hard to take
seriously
of course that's part of the fun but I
don't think that was part of the
characters they're supposed to be a
legitimate threat and martial arts
masters from China are a little bit more
legitimate than martial arts masters
from a dojo next to a grocery store
point goes to the new I like that
attitude
what everybody needs support in a Karate
Kid movie and luckily there's a good
supporting cast to show I guess we
should start with the mothers as they
probably play the biggest role next to
the main heroes and villains the one in
the original is pretty cool she's loving
but also has a tough no-nonsense
attitude
what's with the karate place no it sucks
good I probably couldn't afford it
anyway you can tell she's from Jersey
and she definitely shows the stronger
sides of it very frank and loud but also
very honest and giving himself anything
oh well neither those palm trees run
fair coming out here without asking me
how I felt about it right that was right
there it should have vexed you can
definitely tell these two our mother and
son and get along really well the mother
in the new film is not as strong
I mean sure she's loving and caring but
at times she sort of seems like an
airhead
she's always either screaming for joy
over little things or nagging her son to
hang your coat up for the 100th time can
you please pick up your jacket one
second mom no how many times do I have
to ask you nothing okay just what I
thought nothing I'm probably being too
harsh on her I guess in comparing her to
the other mother she just doesn't seem
as supportive how about the girlfriend
you're both supportive in the generic
movie girlfriend sort of way both are
nice I want to see their boys do well I
guess if I had to choose though I
probably go with the original again
probably the age thing as little
children don't have much control over
what their parents say but even when the
original is forced to be with the bully
she doesn't like she gives him a good
punch in the jaw
this one mostly just looks sad in the
corner so I guess logically the
advantage has to be given to her how
about the other supporting cast that's
about it I mean yeah some brief
characters but they disappear pretty
fast and all the other important people
are well dead
so like guess it's just the girlfriend
and the mother and seeing how I like
both from the original I guess the point
goes to the old huh what do you want me
to do wax on
[Music]
once again it's all tied up and it comes
down to the most important factor this
story
of course the original is the classic
coming-of-age sports movie and the
remake does well to keep faithful to the
material while still adding some new
twists that are the new twist better
than the original or are they just
missing of a classic first of all let's
look at the biggest flaw the fact that
the original teaches karate and the
remake teaches kungfu well then why the
hell isn't it called the kungfu kick
you're calling it karate even though
karate has nothing to do with it it's
like calling a movie Brazil and it has
nothing to do with prison okay bad
example but the point remains if it's
called Karate Kid you better show some
frickin Karate Kung Fu is awesome but
it's just misleading how about the fact
that it's in China and not in the valley
well aside from the fish-out-of-water
story having a bigger impact seeing how
its further across the world it does
allow for a lot of pretty imagery and on
top of that when you hear about the
origins of kung fu it is nice to
actually see the origins of kungfu what
about the relationship between the
student and teacher who do very well in
showing the friendship and you can feel
the bond is very strong with both of
them like I said before though both
films talk about balance and in the new
movie there seems to be a lot more of
that going on the student helps the
teacher through his problems just as
much as the teacher helps the student
this also works with that clever
metaphor with the woman controlling the
snake if she controlling the snake is
this me controlling her or are they
working as one this comes back again
when Shannon Smith are working with each
other after he beats the car
he's pretty cleverly handled speaking of
which let's talk about that big final
fight scene in the new film Smith uses
the understanding of his enemy to his
advantage using the elements of control
and being one to ultimately win the
battle vessel psychology and physical
force that wins the day in the original
it's said that there's a move you can do
where it done right no one can block it
or grainy
doesn't work these do night dope gun
defense bullshit that's a jump kick and
it's very easy to block and even if you
take that out of it you feel like the
kid understood both the philosophy and
the technique of kung fu much more with
this ending than you did with the
original I mean it's there but it's not
as prominent or clever as the remake you
feel like this kid got in more than
Daniel did but the big deciding point
for me was this I realized that the few
things that don't work in the new Karate
Kid are because they had to carry it
over from the original Karate Kid the
typical bullies the over-the-top
villains the keeping the lovebirds apart
just so they can get back together again
if you took these cliches out and just
made it about a kid who wanted to
understand kung fu from a wise master
while also adjusting to a social life
this probably would have been a stronger
movie I mean it's good but it would have
been better
it's the cliches of the original that
holds it back a lot of cliches of the
original aren't great and fun to laugh
at they are still very over useless
shades even for bangbang at times the
original is so good it almost seems real
a lot of the conversations they have
seem very warm and out of everyday life
but at the same time you have those
incredibly overused characters and movie
moments that constantly suck you out of
that reality while they're entertaining
they're still distracting the new film
knows it's a movie it never tries to be
real life because of that it never
oversteps it's bound it keeps the
balance much better so by definition the
new film must be the superior picture it
knows more what it is and what it's
trying to accomplish there's certainly a
passion to the original that the new
film never quite meets as strongly but
it's still jumbled with over-the-top
scenes that frankly makes it
inconsistent this film is consistent it
picks a tone it tells the story and it
does it very well even though the
original will still most likely remain
the best-known it's this film that seems
more carefully put together and when you
get down to it it's the better movie
so the winner by just a little bit is
the new Karate Kid the superior film
Oh bullshit I'm going home
[Music]
so thanks for joining me I hope you had
a lot of fun and excuse me I have quite
a few karate-kick cartoons to catch up
[Music]
I like
versus it is